[Müzik]
Öncelikle merhaba
Bu akşam gerçekten aranızda olmak büyük
bir heyecan Benim için de özellikle
böyle güzel bir konuş
madan ya Ben doktor Seçkin Aydın Savaş
ben Plastik cerrahım
size bugün herkesin hayatındaki dönüm
noktasında sorduğu bir soru vardır benim
hayatımdaki dönüm noktası da Sorduğum
soru iştiyse ben nasıl Var olacağımdı
Benim
var olduğum bir hayattaki varoluş
çabasıydı
yenilik var olmanın tek yolu evraka
dediğim gün plastik cerrahi
asistanlığına başladım ilk günlerde
elime en önemli faks bokumuzu aldığım
zaman
Facebook'ta yazan ilk cümleler plastik
cerrahinin var oluşuyla ilgili iti
anladım ki derya deniz olan bu benim
dalı tepeden tırnağa çevrimiçten geriye
kadar
her türlü bilimin istilasını açık bir
benim
Peki nasıl var olmayı başarıyor yeni
fikirler Yeni prosedürler ve Yeni
teknikler sayesinde
Peki
İnovasyon nedir
opsiyon yeni bir fikre değer yaratan bir
çıksıya dönüştürmek
Eser gibi bir akademik eseri yaratırken
de yeni bir fikir buluyorsunuz ve bunu
bir esere dönüştürmemiz
gerekiyor yeni bir kolay mı
Hayır o kadar kolay değil Konfor sonunda
çıkmak
konforjonunda farklı davranmak inanın
hiç kolay değil Peki yenilik Konfor
sonunda çıkmadan bize gelebiliyor
mu Hayır maalesef mutlaka kafamızı
Konfor uzağından bir çıkartıp bir
bakmamız gerekiyor
bize engel olan nedir
bu konudan çıkmaması engelle yani şey
nedir maalesef hepimizin içindeki stati
sevimli görülen statik ucu gerçekten
yeniliklere ulaşmamızı
engelleyebiliyor dikkat etmemiz
gerekiyor
Ben de Tutar Bizi gerçekten güvenli
zondomuzu sağlar ama yenilik olmadan da
bazı şeyleri yapamıyoruz bunları da
göreceğiz
gerçekten yeniliklerin merkezinde
başladım
hayalcisi ameliyatlar olan
kol rahim nakli gibi
yüz nakli gibi ameliyatların
gerçekleştirildi Profesör Doktor Ömer
Özkan ve Özlenen Özkan'ın liderliğinde
kimi Merkez olan Akdeniz Üniversitesi
Plastik böyle konuştuk cerrahi
alınabilir durumda her şey çok güzeldi
akademik bir kariyer düşünüyorsunuz tam
göbeğindesiniz yenilikler sağ olsun
iyi ekiple iyi hocalarla Bu çok da zor
olmuyordu
ama
benim varoluş sancım başarılı
asistanlığın bittikten sonra başladı
uzman olduktan sonra
akademisyen olmak
[Müzik]
istiyor Yeni bir fikir
bulmanın ve bu yeni Fikri yeni bir esere
çevirmeniz gerekiyor ki
akademisyenlikte başarılı olabilir
sin kendi kanatlarımla uçmak kendi
ayaklarımın üzerinde durma zamanıydı
şimdi
Yeni bir fikir bulmak kolay mı
çok kolay değil tekrar ve tekrar
denemeler olmuyor Çok zor
benim aklıma geldiyse başka birinin
aklında çoktan gelmiştir denemiştir
cümleleri
gerçekten bir yere kadar sizinle beraber
olabiliyor bir yerden sonra
ve bir şekilde Sizin terk ediyor
Evet benim imkanlarım yok
teknolojik olana kadarım yok bir
ekibim hiç yok
nasıl var olacağından
bir şekilde var olmanın Yollarına baktım
benim yeni fikir bulmamı 3 tanesi
gerçekten yaşanmış bir tanesi de şu anda
Yaşadığım bir süreçle anlatacağım size 4
maddeye
farklılık
ları buldu
[Müzik]
ve
okuyuşumuzdan uyuşumuza
konuşmamızdan davranış şekillerimize
kadar her şeyde bir farklılıkmaya çalış
değil ki yeni bir şey yaratmak Yeni bir
fikir bulmak
O kendini
[Müzik]
farklılık
ları ben Bu farklılıklarımı nasıl
yeni bir esere
dönüşebilirdim
yen
iliğe adım atmış oldum
tek tek anlamlı ya da anlamsız bütün
yaptığım cerrahi farklı teknikleri kalem
not aldım
Daha sonrasında bu farklılıkları
gerçekten değiştirebilir miydim
değer katabilir miydim yeni bir esere
dönüştürebilirim ki yaptım birçok
makalemi birçok çalışmamı bu madde
sayesinde kazandım
ikinci madde
[Müzik]
açılmamız gerekiyorsa
B planıyla Bu daha kolay Ben Derin
denizlere inmek zorundaydım
neden bir cerrahi Tekniki vardı
gerçekten ekip gerektiren zorlu bir
cerrahi yöntemi var mı
tabii ki o da yok
Ama ben bu ameliyatı yapmak istiyordum
ve bu ameliyatı yaptıktan sonra
ben yeni bir destanasyona varacaktım
tekrarını belirledim
öyle bir B planı ki bu
Bir de o derin denizde kaybolma
ve bol olmamamı sağlayacak bir b
planıydı hasta mı bu B planımı da
güzelce anlattım ona yine aldım ve
böylelikle ameliyata girdik Ayşe çok mu
güzel mutlu mutlak başarı a planında
Hayır maalesef ben Ameliyat sırasında B
planına geçmek zorunda kaldım hasta olup
bu hasta iyileşti ama benim elimde kalan
sadece bir b planıydı
bu tarz ameliyatlarda ben bu B planını
kurtarıcı bir bot olarak yeni bir esere
yeni bir yayına dönüştürdüm ve bundan
sonra B planı botumla girdiğim derin
denizlerde a planında başarılı sonuçlar
elde edebildim
ve artık beni denizlerde
imkansızlık
her zaman bizimle beraber olabilecek bir
şey
hiçbir zaman
[Müzik]
her şeyde olmayacak
Umarım olur umarım her şeye
ulaşabileceğiniz bir konumda olursunuz
ama hep dahanın dahası vardır
gerçekten
imkanlarınızın yetmediğini göreceksiniz
o zaman da şunu düşünmenizin istiyorum
arkadaşlar imkanların azlığı Hayal
gücünün fazlalığını getirir
Evet evet bu sefer de gerçekten
zor bir ameliyata
sayfalarca
facebook'larda aliteratürde
ameliyata baş koymuştum ben bunu
yapacağız o zaman sadece
ve
bunun endoskopik olarak
onlara neredey
se
her kongreye Gittiğimde her sunumu
yaptım da arkadaşlarım hocalarım Nereden
aklına geldi bu ekipmanı kullanmak
Nereden aklına geldi bu malzemeyi
kullanmaktadır yok dedim bana hiç Öz
yokluktandı
her yaşadığım zorlukta O ameliyat
tekniğine baş koydum İlk günden başladım
ilk ameliyat günlerim de ilk
ameliyatlarım
da alacak haldeydim
ama her yaşadığımız zorlukta Yeni bir
teknik geliştirdim yeni bir ekipman
tasarladım
böylelikle bu büyük ameliyatları da
gerçekleştirebildim arkadaşlar Gerçekten
ekibimiz olmayacak Belki yeterli
teknolojimiz olmayacak
olmayacak ama
hayalleriniz hep sizin
le oldu hocam o kadar güzel anlattı ki
Meltem Hocam gerçekten Albert einste çok
sevdiğim bir sözü vardır mantık sizi a
noktasından sadece B noktasına
götürebilir ama hocanın da dediği gibi
hayal gücü Her yere götürür
ler bunu unutmuyorsunuz olur mu
Benim dördüncü madde hayat hala bana
öğretileri ile donatmaya devam ediyor
vazgeçmek vazgeçmek her zaman bir
yenilgi değildir
vazgeçmek gerçekten bir tüy kadar hafif
Olmaktır Özgür Olmaktır vazgeçmek yeni
Ufuklara gidebilmek için
cesarettir Umarım bu yeni öğretilerim
bir sonraki TEDES konuşmamızda çok
değerli çıktılara dönüşür ve ben bunları
sizinle paylaşabilirim dinlediğiniz için
çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]
[Müzik]